okay baby so if I was to make I'm the
executive director of the Arts
Initiative in science theater and it is
a very great pleasure to welcome all of
you here today for this creative
conversation we are joined today by
Deborah Collin who until very recently
was the director and chief curator
through all of her gallery care and
campus she's not the executive director
of The Rock Stadium so not too far still
close very close in our hearts and and
we're joined by the Arafura Minaya and
this representing the sixth
collaboration that me millimeter
halftime with the wallet art gallery
where we commissioned a visual artist to
make a piece for this lot of space
really it's a Dominican American
multidisciplinary artist whose work
deals with identity other consciousness
interventions and digital intervention
yeah
solution and my
so with this idea of the pristine
depiction of the landscape and then
secondly here is this little QR codes
that are embedded into the wallpaper
like the first one also got QR codes and
I like Danielle people exploring the
landscape because it kind of brings up
these associations of like the explorers
from the century to go over what you're
offering is all there sorts of things
[Applause]